this location is to Mark the 25th
anniversary of this is a body I've been
spoke to many times over the years when
it was the
um
British Irish parliamentary group and
now the assembly but today we had a good
discussion John Holmes who was the key
Civil Servant for Tony Blair at the time
just to reflect back on the the
agreement and to try and take questions
from the members I was particularly
anxious to stress the the importance of
the East West because I think it's
sometimes forgotten that the importance
of the East West and it set out in the
agreement because now we're at the UK
out of brexit there's not the same
connection or association between and
politicians but not only politicians but
the the working groups of civil servants
and so I think they some people call on
the necessity of having some new body to
do that there's no need for a new body
the East West Arrangements undergo
private agreement are already designed
to do that and so I do hope that as we
go forward with the UK out of it and
hopefully with these institutions here
in storm there are back up and running
again that will able to see it an
enhanced role for the at the East West
relationships under the The Good Friday
agreement
s chair what do you think would be a
reasonable period of time
and these proposals and make their
position clear well I I don't I'm not
into the job of potent pressure but I
think any reasonable interpretation I've
read the full documents now
I've talked to several legal people
who've read the full documents so uh but
so I think that end of the process has
finished nowadays the clarifications and
I think it's reasonable in a document
that is so lenting and so many legal
backgrounds that people will have
clarifications particularly
both legal clarifications and just
working mechanisms how these things are
going to work in effect but it would
seem like a few weeks is a reasonable
time if you
have
um
yeah I was taking up from from what the
independent commission's work is the
commission does Tim O'Connor and Monica
Williams and John mcbroney and others
are Major Reese are involved in and they
uh in their recent report uh which
covers all of of last year and 2021 2022
and they're strongly making the point
that they have made a recommendation uh
that a private military groups
um not in any hostile way but that they
trying to bring them into the normal
process and trying to see their closure
is an essential issue and I think they
they have written several pages in the
report of the importance of this we
don't seem to hear too much about that
and I think they're they're the people
who are tasked both to communicate and
to talk to them so I think it is a very
important issue because as we move
forward to normality I think 25 years on
it's fair to be saying that we should
see an organized and debate and what
they're saying is and I know some
members of of of the of this body have
also been saying that and is that there
shall be a an active involvement with
the groups that's not a question of
forcing something it's an act
involvement with them to bring an end to
paramiliters and as we've known it for
Generations
Five Years on but with all of the
institutions suspended does this mean
morning a week
well hopefully it it'll be back up and
running again I made the point that
there's the two and those the two issues
um there's one is to
the peace dividend one and then uh the
political one but
um you know it'd be some way could fall
across the world like this last week
people have been talking about the Good
Friday agreement you know I've seen it
on CNN and Australia and Canada so I
think people around the world are
actually
following this very closely on doing an
interview later on with German the
German media so you know I think people
are anxious to see the outworkings of
this so hopefully we'll see the Good
Friday agreement with all its
imperfections move on in the next few
weeks do you think there's any
yeah I think if people want to uh if
people wanted to to be I can see it if
like clarifications I don't know how
many clarifications are necessary and
but you know
had rushing soon I can't
continue to give this uh High preference
as we've been doing now for several
months indefinitely
um watching the media every day as
you're reporting every day and your
colleagues across the water there's a
lot of issues to deal with and he can't
be sitting around so I think these these
issues should be possible to do with
them fairly quickly
what are your views of these
for certain parties
on for reforms but as I was saying this
morning I think getting institutions up
and running and then have the debate
about there's a review mechanism in the
agreement and there are a number of
issues people want to raise Alliance
have been very strong about their issues
but I think they should all be looked at
but not in advance of the institutions
being up and running I think it's hugely
important that the institutions get up
and run as quickly as possible when
that's a week two or three four but and
then you can review whatever outstanding
issues are there but I do agree and it's
it's not
um Democratic to have Democratic
institutions brought down so so
frequently that's certainly not a good
idea
maybe a different topic a lot of
speculation
of video alone for the arrows that's a
speculation about a lot of things I keep
away from that all I did was join my my
local uh common branch in drunkondron
that led to all kinds of speculation so
don't listen to that to it
I didn't say that
I didn't say that either
thanks very much